what I want to start thinking about in
this video is given that we do have a
monopoly on something and in this
example in this video we're going to
have a monopoly on oranges given that we
have a monopoly on oranges and a demand
curve for oranges in the market how do
we maximize our profit and to answer
that question we're going to think about
our total revenue in different four
different quantities and from that we'll
get the marginal revenue for different
quantities and then we can compare that
to our marginal cost curve and that
should give us a pretty good sense of
where what quantity we should we should
produce to optimize things so let's just
let's just figure out total revenue
first so obviously if we produce nothing
if we produce zero quantity we'll have
nothing to sell you know revenue is
total revenues price times quantity your
price is six but your quantity is zero
so your total revenue is going to be
zero if you produce nothing if you
produce one unit and this over here is
actually 1,000 pounds per day and we'll
call a unit a thousand pounds per day if
you produce one unit then your total
revenue is one unit times five dollars
per pound so it'll be five times
actually 1,000 so it'll be five thousand
dollars and you could also view it as
the area as the area of this rectangle
right over here you have the height is
price and the width is quantity but we
can plot that five times one if you
produce one unit you're going to get
five thousand dollars so this right over
here is in thousands thousands of
dollars and this right over here is in
thousands of pounds thousands of pounds
just to make sure that we're consistent
with this right over here let's keep
going
so that was this point or when we
produce one thousand pounds we get five
thousand dollars if we produce two
thousand pounds if we produce two
thousand pounds now we're talking about
our price is going to be four dollars or
if we can say our price is four dollars
we're gonna we can sell 2,000 pounds
given this demand curve and our total
revenue is going to be the area of this
rectangle right over here height is
price
width is quantity four times two is
eight so if I produce two thousand
pounds then I will get a total revenue
of eight thousand dollars so this is
seven and a half eight is going to put
us something
right right about there and then we can
keep going if I produce or if the price
is $3 per pound
I can sell 3000 pounds my total revenue
is this rectangle right over here three
times three is nine thousand dollars so
if I produce three thousand pounds I can
get a total revenue of nine thousand
dollars so right right about there and
let's keep going if I produce or if the
price is $2,000 or is if the price is $2
per pound
I can sell four thousand pounds my total
revenue is two times four which is eight
thousand dollars so if I produce four
thousand pounds I can get a total
revenue of eight thousand dollars it
should be even with that one right over
there just like that
and then if I produce or if the price is
$1,000 I'm looking for new colors if the
price is $1 per pound I should say I can
produce I can sell five thousand pounds
my total revenue is going to be one
times five or five thousand dollars so
it's going to be even with this year so
if I produce five thousand units I can
get five thousand dollars of revenue and
if I if the price is zero the market
will demand six thousand pounds per day
if it's free but I'm not gonna generate
any revenue because I'm going to be
giving it away for free so I will not be
generating any revenue in this situation
so our total revenue curve it looks like
and if you've taken algebra you would
recognize this as a as a as a downward
facing parabola our total revenue our
total revenue looks like this our total
revenue it's easier for me to draw a
curve with that dotted line our total
revenue looks something like that and
you can even solve it algebraically to
show that it is this downward facing
parabola the formula right over here of
the demand curve its y-intercept is six
so if I wanted to write price as a
function of quantity we have price is
equal to it's equal to 6 minus quantity
or if you wanted to write it in the
traditional slope-intercept form or MX
plus B form and if that doesn't make any
sense you might want to review some of
our algebra playlists you could write it
as
is equal to negative Q plus 6 obviously
these are the same exact thing you have
a y-intercept of 6 you have a
y-intercept of 6 and you have a negative
1 slope if you if you increase quantity
by 1 you decrease price by 1 or another
way to think about it if you decrease
price by 1 you increase quantity by 1 so
that's why you have a negative 1 slope
so this is price as a function of
quantity what is total revenue
well total revenue total revenue is
equal to price times quantity but we can
write price as a function of quantity we
did it just now this is what it is so we
can rewrite it or we could even rewrite
it like this we can rewrite the price
part as so this is going to be equal to
negative Q plus 6 times quantity times
quantity and this is equal to total
total revenue and then if you multiply
this out you get total revenue is equal
to Q times Q is negative Q squared plus
6 plus 6 Q so you might recognize this
this is a this is clearly a quadratic
since you have a negative out front
before the before the second-degree term
right over here before the Q squared it
is a downward-opening parabola so it
makes complete sense now I'm going to
leave you there in this video because
I'm trying to make an effort not to make
my videos too long but in the next video
what we're going to think about is what
is the marginal revenue we get at each
at for each of these quantities and just
as a review just as a review marginal
revenue marginal revenue is equal to
change in total revenue change in total
revenue divided by change in quantity or
another way to think about it the
marginal revenue at any one of these
quantities is the slope is the slope of
the line tangent to that point and you
really have to do a little bit of
calculus in order to actually calculate
slopes of tangent lines but we'll
approximate it with a little bit of
algebra but we're essentially want to do
is figure out the slope so if we wanted
to figure out the marginal revenue when
we're selling 1,000 pounds so exactly
how much more total revenue do we get if
we just barely increase if we just start
selling another
millions of pounds of oranges what's
going to happen and so what we do is
we're essentially trying to figure out
the slope of the tangent line at any of
at any at any point and you can see that
because the change the change in total
revenue is this change in total revenue
is that and change in quantity and
change in quantity is that there so
we're trying to find the instantaneous
slope at that point or you could think
of it as the slope of the tangent line
and we'll continue doing that in the
next video